So let's see if we can
figure out a RAID 1 array.
Suppose we have a RAID 1
array with two disks, and for
a single disk we have a 200GB capacity,
10 MB per second throughput and
the MTTF of 100,000 hours.
In that case, our two disk RAID 1 array
has a data capacity of how many GB,
a throughput of how many MB per second,
assuming that we do equal
numbers of reads and writes, and
finally our MTTF is
equal to how many hours?
And for this type of RAID,
we also need to know whether we
replace failed disks or not, so here,
assume that we do replace the failed
disk and that the mean time to repair,
meaning the mean time it takes us to
replace the failed disk, is 24 hours.